uh welcome everybody to another league
of legends business Q&A livestream i got
my fresh haircut and shave i missed a
beard already super fine but ready to
get into a game helping some
entrepreneurs let me accept this invite
i have my usual playing partner Jay
rises in as fresh fuse and my usual
coast Rishi captive eu-russia welcome
aboard Thank You Evan glad to be here
loaded cup of love I yeah I got I'm only
had my cup of water I have my vitamin
water Alex brought me a coffee it's
somewhere uh I gotta make my yogi tea
with my message of the day I like did I
read yesterday's message the day well
you didn't have your yoga yeah it was a
good one it's like ha what was it it was
something about the the person that you
are fighting with is yourself or
something like that like the other put
the other thing understanding that the
other person is you or something it was
I mean they're usually deep but it was
new level of deep this time so I read it
like all this and have it on the
livestream I was so excited by them and
that is the truth that is the truth who
we are fighting ourselves most the die
so what's what what's in the cup cup of
love and then what are you drinking
today um well so I have community coffee
today uh not a huge fan but we press on
all right listen did anything happen
with the the suggestions around thus the
how to sweeten your coffee you mean like
the natural sweetener yeah cuz you we're
trying to we're trying to be able to
allow Rishi to enjoy her coffee twice a
day oh my god there were a few
suggestions in the child a few days ago
yeah it was very controversial event
because I saw some people tell me to put
honey in my coffee and and I just
can't I can't do it all right
controversial Reese's living on the edge
here all right this is Cheyenne sweet
wait yeah we can your beer is time you
know like if it's like some kind of
YouTube friends because you have a beard
you shaved your beard tim has always had
a beard since lawyer always had feared
he shaky search then I see dottotech who
I don't know if you watch him he's
another techie expert on YouTube he has
like this full on beard which he's never
had before I know it's gonna come on now
attitude no it's just now he has this
like long beard oh listen it's self
expression is it really like you guys
really feel like strongly I mean I know
there's this whole like beard trend but
like you're not a hipster I know that so
what's what's your feelings about your
connection to your beard and
self-expression that's it it's self
expression she sometimes I like having
it sometimes I don't I get I you know
Nina has an aversion to it so I can't
give it like massively long but also
when it gets too long ago to itch but
I've also like shave stuff in the side
of my head mm-hmm that's it just like
why do you want to I'd it why do women
dye their hair or curly hair straighten
their hair put highlights in her hair
she's another form of expression I hear
ya it's it experimenting with your
coffee you know do the same time left
it's going did you know that you can get
your eyelashes permed now I'm trying to
visualize that okay I have really long
eyelashes fun facts about heaven today I
have really long eyelashes women
middleweight anyone would kill for my
eyelashes all right good well now that
we're massively off topic let's say you
do some shadow to do got we got
zeno in the house and obviously Jaso
forged welcome guys optus horas de masta
I'm excited because guys we hit a
thousand views on the twitch channel
look at that there we go o night yeah
it's getting up there building something
special the new empire alright well as
we pick our champions Jay rises mid you
can't play rise because rise has been
disabled temporarily so he's going to be
Victor I'm going to try to get my t-mo
jungle and let's get into some questions
this helps much for nurse what we got
okay first question is coming from
Robert and Robert is yeah Robert said
here is what I'm contacting you today
I'm creating a social club excuse me
start again I'm creating a social social
group club whose primary goal is to add
value to entrepreneurs meetups webinar
seminars workshops Lunch and Learn
retreats and more these meetings will
have a basic purpose of providing others
with skills knowledge and opportunities
to achieve the greatness we all deserve
by the way Evan this is I think he is in
Toronto okay so he wants to start this
group and this is a start up from the
ground up I'm starting with near nearly
zero capital budget I believe it will be
successful as I've been preparing for
this some time now I'm ready to launch
but I must have value to share in order
to achieve the success i expect as my
first session it is my intention to host
a pitch session for entrepreneurs there
will be a speed pitch opportunity to
pitch on stage as well as presentations
or experienced entrepreneurs and coaches
this is where I'm hoping you could help
I see the cost for having you at an
event and I could not exactly afford you
that will not stop me from content
can use merely a challenge to overcome I
hope that we can speak and demonstrate
the value of this vent and demonstrate
the value of this venture I hope to be a
part of the 1 billion entrepreneurs you
you might find some way to help me
achieve my entrepreneurial dreams and he
loves the book he's looking forward to
your book Robert okay um cool so love of
course I know you sound like you're as
excited you know it definitely sounds
like you are just excited to help
entrepreneurs which is super cool love
that you're from Toronto and it sounds
like a great idea I think my my initial
reaction to his idea is as great as an
ideas it is and I think you absolutely
can achieve the idea is like there's
such a learning curve between your
really good idea and then executing and
so I think we can all just have these
really perfect plans and then spend so
much time investing in this plan but not
actually just start doing something with
what you have right now you know like
what value can you start giving right
now do you know you don't have to do
this like perfect launch where
everything is been perfectly in place
before you get started can you just
start right now giving value in the
small that you do have and then build it
up to this bigger dream that I think
he's seeing and I wouldn't probably be
reaching out to influencers yet because
i would probably test it first and
really prove that it's something that
you want to do that you really like
doing you know once you again once you
start executing it's like a whole nother
animal so I think it's a great idea I
think you'll absolutely it's totally a
you know within reach i just think maybe
start
something on now and then see how it
goes I don't that's all I have yeah I
mean I love the passion for
entrepreneurs obviously there's an
alignment there and being in Toronto's
amazing too I think what do I think as I
listen to this my initial my initial
thought is for you really figuring out
the business model it's super hard to
sell the entrepreneurs and you you you
either play in the space where it's free
and you build a huge traction you build
you know a lot of people coming out and
then you sell sponsorships and you work
with you work with big companies banks
and telcos and technology companies and
all those guys we're trying to reach
entrepreneurs and have them spot to your
event or you go more high-end and give
give successful entrepreneurs a way to
connect with each other getting
entrepreneurs to pay for things is
really hard like ten dollars to come up
to an event is super hard it's like
herding cats and a lot of people have
tried in Toronto and and I've had a hard
time getting off the ground and so I
would love to see your business model I
try to figure out how that might work I
think in terms of building an event if
you don't have any audience or traction
yet you know of any budget what I would
recommend is trying to do something with
the bdc which is business dry land bank
of canada they support entrepreneurs the
government organization or enterprise
toronto same thing another government
organization or any of the incubators
around try to organize using the
built-in communities of existing
organizations so enterprise toronto i
think has you know a hundred thousand
people plus and their email list
um they do an annual event you know
would they partner with you on a
different kind of event by the way we're
in game I'm Timo jungle gr Isis Victor
made looks like one of our players is
not joining in so that's interesting and
it's not that is not a good start oh
he's here okay yes I love it um yeah to
build momentum to build traction so that
you're going after whoever it is that
you want to have speak or pitch to that
you can say I've got the these
organizations on board to help promote
this event you're gonna need a space
right so can you do it at enterprise
Toronto can you do it at you know the
the bdc headquarters can you do it at
any of these places it's going to be
there's a lot to figure out and I love
that you're on this path I would just
try to build up a little bit more
momentum before approaching people
because I don't want you to get rejected
and then you don't have it's hard to go
back a second time right so I don't know
who else is on your list of people that
you would want to have their if you're
doing a pitch fest and you need people
who are active angel investors and it's
way easier to get media on board and
partners on board than it is to get the
headliners on board especially if you
don't if you're not going to pay them
hey we got first blood exciting it's a
good start oh and we died very sad so I
think that's how it start and it's a
good lesson in just building momentum in
general for entrepreneurs find the
easiest side of the equation and start
building around that in this case you
know the hardest part is going to be
getting getting the talent to come
getting the the headliners to come so
why would they come they're going to
come because they see an opportunity for
their brand they love the cause you know
they love the the mission and they seal
of the momentum that you built up so go
up and build up momentum now there's a
lot of media who would love to cover
this
right there a lot of organizations that
would love to partner up with you help
you promote it if you have the vision
for you know as an example when I was
first starting into this kind of arena
myself the first thing i did locally was
at a YMCA and we use their space and I
spoke out of their location which is
great and then we eventually got
partners with rel bank which is the
biggest bank in Canada to help be our
partner and then eventually I got too
big for ymca and so i'm likejust their
location was too small so we moved into
the Royal Bank offices and they helped
promote it and then we got too big for
Royal Bank so I moved into chapters
which is like barnes and noble for you
guys the books nor and and i started
doing regular events there and we had
the second-most number of people to show
up anaheim tenure and the only person
who had more people show up that year to
an event with sting was promoting to one
of our purposes like that's pretty cool
uh I thought was anything that was the
start of my entrepreneurial you know
giving back an advice I didn't even have
a business model around it it was just I
wanted to help entrepreneurs yeah so I
formed these partnerships right first
with the YMCA and then with the the bank
and then with you know chapters which
barnes and noble so figuring out those
alliances they helped me kind of every
step along the way long i get it back
come on back back back could be really
helpful for you and then once you start
building traction if you say hey listen
i'm parting with roll bank and i
partnered with XYZ all these people and
the media wants to cover it then when
you're going and talking to people it's
a lot easier for them to say yes because
you've done mm-hmm you've done some
groundwork and it's so much easier to
get the media and those partnerships and
it is to get
headliners so I love it I love the
mission keep me posted yeah absolutely
and um evan is that the continuation
that I'm sorry that is the long echo or
those allowed to echo again what that
happens content anonymous was that the
continuation of your stories from the
ymca yeah I guess I've never told that
story as much I did the YMCA and I can't
get a lot of you guys know that I you
know I set this thing out there's this
big free event that I was promoting and
working hard on and then only three
people showed up but I did it anyway
because you know three people showed up
and it was a test for me and I loved it
so I said I have to find a way to keep
going I have to find a way to keep doing
this thing and so I I did I kept doing
more at the YMCA and then we just got
too many people coming out with time it
wasn't like hey next the next month was
you know a thousand people showed up you
know it built yeah we had three the
first time and seven the next time and
then ten the next time just like
anything else just like my youtube
channel just like this twitch channel
just like anything else that you work on
it takes time to build up and it takes
time for you to get better at it hone
your craft so yeah then we outgrew the
space and move into a bank and we could
add space into the bookstore and then
we're getting so many people and then at
that time I'd also started a new
business and I and it was taking up like
I had to kind of focus my time and I
stopped doing that and then move more to
online stuff while doing more I kept
doing speaking but more for
organizations or events as opposed to
hosting my own
so yeah yeah it was fun good times I
realized hide and Chloe story so there
we go yeah because I think most people
hear that story and they think you
usually tell a story is like I'm sorry
to echo is it it's very great butt
meaning that i can burn myself I could
turn you down and just don't know people
are gonna hear you oh really okay cuz
you're you're being recorded through my
speakers yeah lets you just in a little
bit um most people hear that story and I
usually say like I only had three people
there and they don't know what Vanessa
but it's a cool name individual it
really wasn't just 38 ended up being a
winning of a movement yeah and the most
important part of that was it is it was
beginning of my movement like I it was
self discovery for me that I want to do
this um and and the early days were I
mean amazing a lot of fun like those we
had a small group and then we would go
to a local coffee shop either starbucks
or second cup which is a Canadian chain
and just sit and chill and talk business
for the next you know two hours so it
was it was a good good good loyal group
you know just like the people who come
to this twitch chat it's a good small
consistent loyal group and then you know
with time we we built it up and it grew
and didn't know everybody as deacon
personally but there's always the
beginning is always that you know
hardcore group of the start super cool
alright next question comes from Drew
bucks dhruba career value dhruva okay
perfect
in dhruva said I'm from India and I'm in
search for a mentor I'm a regular viewer
of your channel lately i'm applying most
of the techniques of self-mastery in my
life a young entrepreneur who is in the
early stages of building a company also
going through really rough times
financially yet i'm working on myself
deliberately i strongly feel that i am a
teacher a mentor who can guide me on my
tat I'm very dedicated and persistent
please take me under your wing and I
promise that whatever I learned from you
i will share it with people around I
believe I truly believe but sometime I
have a hard time around people my daily
routine he goes into a routine and yeah
I just kind of saying whatever you know
I'm something is really excited to apply
knowledge and advice and so he's asking
for guidance alright so yeah we get this
definitely a lot a lot of people
inspired by what you're doing Evan and
wanting more and work guidance and so
yeah I totally understand that because
especially if you're just new to
anything you know can be scary when
you're trying to learn something new you
want to make an impact and you just
don't know where to start and it just
can be something that is scary to do on
your own and so the need for guidances I
mean I I think we all can relate with
that I would suggest that you continue
to watch the channel because I so much
yeah I always say this channel and to
you and university you can learn
anything you
really want pretty much and you know it
goes a long way if you have a lot of
desire hunger to learn I love it and
when you say you know there's people who
start out who had even less then you
know you have and they need it work so
there's a lot to be said about pursuing
what you want to do and being
resourceful in getting that the
information you need and then just if
you would like that extra personal help
you know I would look into locally
people because mentorship implies a
relationship and so I think the better
thing would be to maybe try to form
relationship with someone locally where
you can actually i'm really not locally
we're living in an online world is
there's just someone that you could
contact check in with regularly that
would be able to provide that for you
but I'm trying to give some extra value
i know we get this question a lot Evan
yeah one you know I so I mean the
typical response we've given is one hey
you like you already are being mentored
continue to watch the videos you need to
learn continue to grow there's something
that you you know people you want to
learn from this there's a host there's a
wealth of experience on the channel that
comes out every day for you guys for
free to consume and enjoy and learn i
love the ain't you analogy that's fun um
yeah and in terms of of beyond that the
last thing you want to do is go in and
ask for someone to to mentor you because
again it does reply imply that
relationship which nobody's going to
sign up for like I love the I love the
heart and the passion and the energy
that you have
but a way better way to do it is to ask
a specific question ask one question
what is it that you want help with who
do you need advice with him and that's
it like what's the most important thing
that you need some guidance with and I
wish there was something and look in the
comment there that we could latch on to
and say hey here's some good advice for
you to go and apply right what are you
going through right now in your life for
your business that beyond just you know
general stuff that we might be able to
help you with and that's the path in and
it I mean well Jay gotta kill it's good
to it's good to keep bringing up because
we keep getting the questions and so
hopefully you know what time people will
the message will sink in that the best
way to start that kind of relationship
is right in calling you know whatever it
is with one question get some feedback
apply the feedback and then go back for
a second question and then maybe a third
question right they want to see that
you're you're doing the work mm-hmm you
have to be doing the work because a
mentorship does imply a long-term
relationship and again nobody's gonna
nobody's going to marry you on the first
date or before even dating right mm-hmm
so I'm for everybody right now with
questions give us a specific question we
can help you with because that's what
for both of us that's what we like doing
that's why that's why we do this that's
why we do this here so it was a specific
question we can give you some guidance
with mm-hmm all right I think I think to
just I've been thinking about the last
question and this question I think it
exudes a lot of the times we don't
realize like to get to the bigger thing
like we start with the bigger thing
whether it's like the big event or the
mentorship whereas we don't recognize
that those things come in
like the steps and stages and so we
don't take that step because we're fixed
on the big big big picture and so like
you said it doesn't look like it's what
you want because it's like oh I don't
want to just ask you a question and then
you and that's it like I want to full-on
mentorship relationship but it's like
recognizing the process of anything
starts with that little deaf and how you
how you manage that little step
determines how you receive the bigger
steps and so it's like everybody gets
excited about the big thing but we don't
always recognize the small thing that's
right in front of us that leads to the
bigger thing does that make sense sure
I'd also say as much as possible try to
you know whoever you're dealing with
customers you know investors mentors
really try to put yourself in their
shoes and asked what they would like so
then the first one you know it was a it
was a it was an okay job where he was
like you know I ain't I know that
getting you to speak in the vent is
really expensive okay so what would I
want to see right like ask the next
question because all of the people that
you ideally want if you want to have a
good event you want people who are who
are credible who have an audience who
have a great message you don't want to
have an event of just you know beginner
people because then that's not going to
draw the attention in so what would I
want to see yeah that's a very real
concern okay great you put myself and
you put yourself in my shoes I sorry you
put yourself in white yeah my shoes a
little bit more than take it one step
further and so for this one too with the
mentorship you know you're asking
somebody for help
it's great to be you know it's great to
show hustle it's great to show drive but
again put yourself in that person's
shoes what would they want to see take
it one more step further each time what
would that person want to see to get a
yes on whatever it is that you're asking
what do they need to see and then go out
and try to do that for them love it all
right next question comes from Quincy
Quincy yeah Quincy says hi Evan I live
out here in Toronto but I'm not sure how
to make my own business here I always
knew in my mind since I was a kid that
i'd be a man with a lot of money the
thing is I just do not know where to
start because i do not have an idea what
field i would like to start business
then the next thing i want to do is
invest what I also have no clue about
I'm reaching out to you you have
inspired me and I would like my dream to
become a reality I guess what I'm saying
is I do need guidance on these types of
things since I was never topped up all
right um yeah so he's looking for
guidance on on his entrepreneurial
aspirations as well as and he wants to
invest I guess the feedback that I have
is just kind of similar to even what we
gave the last question is just start and
can you like what what would you be able
to start today in a small measure that
makes you excited and come alive it may
not be the big idea it may not be the
big decision but what can you do today
to start giving value toward an area
that you feel passionate about and that
makes you come alive and that you're
curious about
and start educating yourself as well in
whatever area that is and yeah that's
all I got there I think this is a great
question and if you compare it to the
last one mm-hmm it's along the same
lines but here's a specific question
right so it arms reaching I with the
ability to be able to hopefully help you
because we have a little bit more
context about what's what you're going
through what's important to you in terms
of certain the basin to be thinking
about why you want to start a business
what are you really searching for I
don't know wanting to set of businesses
enough you want to you want to make an
impact somewhere right like if you're
just attracted to I want to start a
business because I can get rich because
I always knew it have a lot of money and
you look at how people make money and
it's you know the richest people a lot
of them are just entrepreneurs and
that's the reason well that's not it's
not a great reason you look the most
successful entrepreneurs in the world
they wanted to make a difference somehow
they had a vision for something like
that's where it starts much more than I
want to be an entrepreneur okay so
that's what i'll be looking for ya just
gotta kill um I think I'd examine for
anything like you know you you want to
uh you want to get married you want to
you know hopefully you're doing it
because you love the person not because
you know they have rich parents and
you're hoping for a great inheritance
you know um well it's along the same
lines like how do I get rich great how
do I make a lot of money okay
entrepreneurship perfect i cost what
this enjoyed in any business that's the
danger that you want to avoid you want
to do a business because you're
passionate about the industry that
you're going into if you don't if you
don't have a passion you don't know what
it is yet then it's exploring
exploring exploring exploring until you
find something that just makes you light
up that it's like man this is it you
know something that you want to you want
to pour a ton of love and effort and
harden to even if you weren't making a
lot of money I kept doing those things
at the YMCA I wasn't making anything
mm-hmm but I just I loved it and that's
what you'll find from a lot of them yes
you need a business model yes you know
you have to make money but money is
never the most important thing for for
any successful entrepreneur that that
we've profiled or that I know of and so
it's finding that thing oh they
surrendered all right good game finding
that thing that is more important than
money for you and going in on that
that's where a business idea will come
from and in terms of investing it's just
doing join the research we won I didn't
I didn't really do much that game I had
one kill that's it all right well good
times J reyez how did he do two kills I
had one so decent decent game um I got
asked yesterday five friend of mine in
the salsa world can you recommend a book
for me for investment or personal
finance for beginners and it's a hard
one for me because because I've had such
a interest in it over time like I think
I will I thought it was gonna be a
banker right but I thought that one was
gonna do and so I I know a lot of this
stuff that I'm not really reading
beginner books on the topic so I had a
hard time recommending it I said I said
every want to check one out look at
Tony's new one but I haven't read it
it's just I'm a fan of Tony's content
and if he's tackling personal finance
there's probably some nuggets in there
for you but it's just learning but again
why why you try to invest in just
because you want to make a ton of money
like find something more important
find something that you're passionate
about that then you can pull your love
into that will provide value to people
you'll make even more money that's what
I got and then could you speak a little
bit too like why now I mean I I can
guess but I am curious to hear what you
have to say like clearly part of this
desire for entrepreneurship comes from
you know pop culture because I think
that's partly why people go oh I just
want to be an entrepreneur because I
know and I'm not saying this is what the
question was about but some people
pursue the entrepreneurship because it's
just like oh I just want to work from
home I just want to I want to make a lot
of money because that's how it's sold a
lot of the time but like you were saying
like that the real passionate
entrepreneurs are the people who just
like whether it's popular or not they
want to just change the world so when
did this start this idea of like pop-pop
entrepreneurship and i might be asking a
very loaded question now so not be for
another time but just kind of curious
like one did it suddenly become so cool
to be of entrepreneurs yeah well i mean
i think that's just backing up i think
is just part of human nature right you
see you see people have it success and
you're like oh I want that and it's not
necessarily what you actually want you
know you see a singer going off and
doing well though I want to sing but you
don't actually want to sing you want the
celebrity in the fame but you don't want
to do the work of practicing and singing
and so you know you're mediocre singer
you're never going to get there with
that with entrepreneurship I think
honestly I think it this you know making
it more fat or popular I think it came
with I think it came with facebook I
think it came with Zuckerberg I think
seems young tech guy making it just
here's this young person who's you know
multi-billionaire on top of the world
it just seems like it's way more
accessible like the people who are
telling us we can't be successful you
know work for a company for 20 years 30
years 40 years and then then you're then
you've made it and not that Zuckerberg
was really uh he's not really a
lightning rod of controversy he's not
saying like stick it to the old people
or you know anything like that he's he's
he's a especially the early days he was
a super boring interview but I think
just seeing this young person on top of
the world inspired a lot of people to
want to go off and do their own thing
and they want to be on the cover of Time
magazine and they want to be worth a
billion dollars but they don't want to
do the work of building a facebook so
you like you're attractive for the wrong
reasons so if I had to pinpoint it but
that's where I would put okay yeah cuz
entrepreneurship has always been there
you might look at a you know Bill Gates
or whoever it is but but they're all
there was they were always you know
especially the older entrepreneurs are
there they were older you know people
who had success where it's not like
someone who is 18 can look at that
person can't look at you know any of the
art refers to the past and say that
person's like me well here's this
university kid killing it hmm so
even like I mean Jobs was in his 20s but
I think just how how easy the message
was the spread and how much attention
Zuckerberg got and how quickly Facebook
grew was just a sign hey maybe I could
do it too and the whole ecosystem around
it like he was the biggest but then the
ton of other people came with him too
and it's great like it's never been
easier to be an entrepreneurs never been
easier to have success has never been
easier to have the impact from a young
age like the things that are holding us
back today versus what used to be in the
way is ridiculously small but that
doesn't mean that you should be an
entrepreneur you know making wanting to
be rich is the worst reason in the world
to be an entrepreneur and i get it and i
get and people look at the magazines and
right it's like okay I'm gonna look at
the wealthiest people in the world how
do they get their most most of them are
it's either inherited wealth or they're
self-made through starting the business
you don't get to be rich by working for
somebody else typically and then people
go in and look at the ink magazine of
the hottest hundred companies in the
country best industries to get into and
you know whatever that is I'm going to
go do that because that's how I make
money great so virtual realities at the
top of the list okay you know nothing
about virtual reality maybe you don't
care a virtual reality right that's you
the answer isn't go learn about virtual
reality the answers go do something else
that you are passionate about because
there's an opportunity there to not just
make a lot of money but have a huge
impact and enjoy the process and enjoy
the work that you're doing in touch
people's lives in addition to making a
lot of money so I got
fascinating alright well it's a fast day
I'm grateful for the speedy victory
other i wish i had more of an impact
here but at least i gotta kill some
painful for that I did something I did
one thing yeah what is where how are we
ending up for you she wants the rishi
message of the day uh well i think just
you know what would you do I love this
message what would you do if you were
never gonna get paid for it you know
what would you do work hard toward and
just lose sleep over even if no one was
paying you for it that's a good place to
start with anybody I love it good food
for thought well thank you guys for
joining me and rishi and j reyez it's
great to see a victory we will be back
tomorrow morning to close the week
strong hopefully i think this is this is
a streak guys this is two games in our
own we've started a little mini street
happening here pretty exciting that's it
having an awesome close to the week
continue to believe and rise and cup or
whatever your one where is i will see
you soon